[Music]
it was a pleasure to burn it was a
special pleasure to see things eaten to
see things blackened and changed
Fahrenheit 451 opens in a blissful blaze
and before long we learn what's going up
in flames Ray Bradbury novel imagines a
world where books are banned from all
areas of life and possessing let alone
reading them is forbidden the
protagonist Montag is a fireman
responsible for destroying what remains
but as his pleasure gives way to doubt
the story raises critical questions of
how to preserve one's mind in a society
where free will self-expression and
curiosity are under fire in Montag's
world mass media has a monopoly on
information erasing almost all ability
for independent thought on the subway
ads blast out of the walls at home
Montag's wife Mildred listens to the
radio around the clock and three of
their parlor walls are plastered with
screens at work the smell of kerosene
hangs over Montag's colleagues who smoke
and set their mechanical hound after
rats to pass the time when the alarm
sounds they surged out in salamander
shaped vehicles sometimes to burn whole
libraries to the ground but as he sets
tomes ablaze day after day like black
butterflies Montag's mind occasionally
wanders to the contraband that lies
hidden in his home
gradually he begins to question the
basis of his work Montag realizes he's
always felt uneasy but has lacked the
descriptive words to express his
feelings in a society where even
uttering the phrase once upon a time can
be fatal
Fahrenheit 451 depicts a world governed
by surveillance robotics and virtual
reality a vision that proved remarkably
prescient but also spoke to the concerns
of the time the novel was published in
1953 at the height of the Cold War this
era kindled widespread paranoia and fear
throughout Bradbury's home country of
the United States
simplified by the suppression of
information and brutal government
investigations in particular this
witch-hunt mentality targeted artists
and writers who were suspected of
communist sympathies Bradbury was
alarmed at this cultural crackdown he
believed it set a dangerous precedent
for further censorship and was reminded
of the destruction of the Library of
Alexandria and the book burning of
fascist regimes he explored these
chilling connections in Fahrenheit 451
titled after the temperature at which
paper burns the accuracy of that
temperature has been called into
question but that doesn't diminish the
novel's standing as a masterpiece of
dystopian fiction dystopian fiction as a
genre amplifies troubling features of
the world around us and imagines the
consequences of taking them to an
extreme in many dystopian stories the
government imposes constrictions onto
unwilling subjects but in Fahrenheit 451
Montag learns that it was the apathy of
the masses that gave rise to the current
regime the government merely capitalized
on short attention spans and the
appetite for mindless entertainment
reducing the circulation of ideas to ash
as culture disappears imagination and
self-expression follow even the way
people talk is short-circuited such as
when Montag's boss captain Beattie
describes the acceleration of mass
culture speed up the film Montag quick
click pic look I now flick hear their
swift pace up down in out why how who
what where uh-huh
bang smack wallop Bing bong boom digest
digests digest digest digests politics
one column two sentences a headline then
in midair all vanishes in this barren
world Montag learns how difficult it is
to resist when there's nothing left to
hold on to all together Fahrenheit 451
is a portrait of independent thought on
the brink of extinction and a parable
about a society which is complicit in
its own combustion dive into other works
of classic literature with our reading
series playlist
[Music]